foreign
this is madness
[Music]
this is Sparta
foreign
and you are watching RT Essentials today
we're celebrating one of the greatest
action stars of our time a Scottish
board multi-faceted artist who has spent
the last two decades building up an
impressive resume of box office matches
I am of course talking about Gerard
Butler Who Rose to Fame after playing
King Leonidas in the stylized hit 300.
I'm sure you're familiar with his work
on screen but did you know that before
pursuing a career in this business
Butler actually graduated from law
school and held a position at a
prestigious firm in Edinboro he was also
the lead singer in a rock band called
speed are you still unimpressed well I
have more he rescues dogs and donates to
Charities that help fight world hunger
yeah that's what I thought you're
impressed now right you better be
clearly Butler can do it all but let's
not forget what he does best he plays
badass roles in films with fights
explosions car chases and imp impressive
stunt work and we've got a whole list of
our absolute favorites right here these
are the best Gerard Butler action movies
den of Thieves
let me ask you this one okay
we look like the types who'll arrest you
put you in handcuffs drag you down to
the station
hmm
you're not the bad guys
we are up first is den of Thieves a
crime Thriller directed written and
produced by Christian gudegast Butler
plays Big Nick O'Brien the hard drinking
leader of The Regulators an elite unit
of the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department
cool name there but not nearly as cool
as the Outlaws who are a gang of
ex-military men using their expertise
and tactical skills to evade the law big
Nick and The Regulators must face off
against the Outlaws who attempt to pull
off an insane Heist robbing the Federal
Reserve in Los Angeles in addition to
Butler the film also Stars Pablo
Schreiber who you might recognize from
The Wire you know one of the greatest TV
shows ever made and 50 Cent who you
might recognize from in the club you
know one of the greatest songs ever made
though the characters and events of this
action are might seem over the top the
movie was Loosely inspired by real life
events and gudegas went to Great Lengths
to ensure that den of Thieves felt as
authentic as possible he even consulted
with the military the LAPD and some
former members of the Hell's Angels and
additionally he worked closely with
officials from the Federal Reserve to
further understand their facility and
how one might actually pull off such a
heist so I'm gonna get out of this one
not sure yet
you get my number from her cell
I ain't cuffing up
that's okay
I'm bringing my coffee way which after
learning that I feel like the film
should come with a do not attempt
disclaimer no like many of Butler's
characters on this list O'Brien is tough
as Nails a ruthless leader who isn't
afraid to put his life on the line for
the greater good but O'Brien isn't your
typical Heist genre protagonist he's
multi-layered struggled with alcohol and
badly wants to fix a strained
relationship with his family Newsday
praised den of Thieves and wrote that
it's like discovering Butler all over
again plus the film grossed over 80
million dollars which is uh more than
you'd make trying to rob the Federal
Reserve building right
just don't do it
Olympus Has Fallen they have command was
roam in the hallways with enough
explosives to take out an army looks
like the doors and windows are rigged
with C4 explosives who knows what other
tricks they have up their sleeves
any team coming in is going to be
ringing a front doorbell pretty loud
they shut the power down lights off and
ice and they close the air vents
and kill the surveillance but I don't
know how long that's gonna last
where's Connor
we have no status of his location but
he's presumed to still be inside
on there looking for him they have his
photo sir
I'm here use me an Olympus Has Fallen a
heavily armed terrorist organization
launches an attack on the White House
and president Benjamin Asher has taken
hostage Butler plays Mike Banning a
secret service agent and former Army
Ranger who must locate Asher's son
before the extreme is due and rescue the
president before his captors unleash
their ultimate plan so this isn't the
most original concept and feels heavily
inspired by the Die Hard franchise but
you really can't beat this cast which
aside from Butler includes Aaron Eckhart
Morgan Freeman Angela Bassett Ashley
Judd and several other Heavy Hitters
obviously each of these actors bring
their A-game to the film but it's Butler
who steals the show with all the hard
and believable grit of action Legends
like Bruce Willis and Harrison Ford
director Anton Fuqua who had his
critical breakthrough with the 2001
Thriller Training Day strikes again here
and makes a film that should be
predictable at every turn but some cow
feels fresh and inventive yes it's kind
of absurd that anyone would ever attempt
to penetrate what might be the most
heavily guarded building on the planet
but you're so busy watching Butler do
his thing you kind of forget all about
the absurdity of the premise yeah
I guess I'm a little rusty
I like your friend though
he seems like a funny guy
what's your Leader's name
oh I'm sorry
how many men do it
in English
on a budget of 70 million Olympus Has
Fallen gross over 170 million finishing
second at the box office at its opening
weekend critics praise fuqua's Direction
with time out writing that the film is
in hard driving good humored command of
its own silliness and additionally top
critic Little White Lies single Dove
Butler for stealing the film and did
anyone think that he wasn't going to
steal a movie like this
[Music]
so we take her to the air base and then
we're gonna stand in there alone when
they turn her away
[Music]
Greenland was directed by Rick Roman wag
and stars Butler as John Garrity a
father along with his wife and son who
embark on a journey to find sanctuary as
a planet-killing comet named Clark
hurdles towards Earth as cities are
getting leveled left and right the
guarantees experience the best of
humanity and also the worst elements of
it as well and now that the countdown to
the global apocalypse is approaching
zero they find themselves in a desperate
fight for a safe haven on the surface
this might seem like your typical
apocalyptic Thriller like Butler's
adjacently premised film video store
maybe but surprisingly this one steers
away from the over-the-top nature of
such films and delivers something that
feels far more grounded and believable
almost too believable there's even one
scene where Garrity receives a QR code
from the Department of Homeland Security
and it's real you can scan that code and
the text garrityjohn will appear on your
smartphone I mean I guess that doesn't
have anything to do with real Comet
hitting Earth but we just thought it was
a super cool detail there every marriage
goes through
that don't mean you get to jump into
another woman's bed
you're right I did
and I'm gonna have to live with that for
the rest of my life
I'm not expecting your forgiveness still
find me a one thing right
I'm gonna give my son and my wife into
that bunker originally Chris Evans was
cast in the film but Butler ended up
replacing him after wag signed on to
direct Butler also produce this one
under the banner of his company gbase
which he formed in 2008 with his manager
Alan Siegel gbase was also behind den of
Thieves and several other successful
films I mean like I mentioned before
this guy can really do it all Greenland
was critically acclaimed with many
praising its elevated premise and
emotional focus and calling it a much
welcomed addition to the disaster genre
Empire magazine called it Butler's best
Star vehicle in years and timeout wrote
that Butler finally faces an adversary
he can't punch really though don't speak
too soon I could see him punching a
comet in the sequel
300. this is where we hold them
where we fight
this is where they die and these shields
boys
remember this
whole time Zack Snyder's 300 is based on
the 1998 comic of the same name created
by Frank Miller and Lynn varlay for
those unfamiliar with this film which is
kind of inexcusable if you consider
yourself a Gerard Butler fan it's set in
480 BC where a state of War exists
between Persia led by King Xerxes and
Greece at the Battle of Thermopylae King
Leonidas Butler leads his badly
outnumbered Spartan Warriors against the
massive Persian army though certain
death awaits the Spartans their
sacrifice inspires all of Greece to
unite against their common enemy yes the
battle scenes are epic and the film is
visually in a category of its own but
the most impressive aspect is how in
shape this cast including Butler was
during production haven't you noticed
we've been sharing our culture with you
all morning shortage is a fascinating
tribe
fight
and the face of annihilation
and the presence of a god
it isn't wise to stand against
meleonidas imagine what horrible fate
awaits my enemies when I would gladly
kill any of my own men for victory and I
would die for anyone
stay true to the original graphic novel
The Script for 300 insisted that the
male cast spend the bulk of their screen
time shirtless and because the Spartans
are considered to be some of the most
physically disciplined Warriors in
history this meant that the actors had
big shoes to fail actually According to
some historians Spartans were forbidden
to wear shoes even in the winter and
during battle big Apes the filth doesn't
matter the point is to get in shape the
principal cast underwent an intense
eight-week training regimen organized by
legendary mountain climber marked flight
according to Butler he trained for six
hours a day and this was one of the most
difficult challenges of his entire
acting career but the hard work
certainly did pay off because 300 was a
box office hit grossing over 456 million
dollars and is directly responsible for
launching Butler into stardom
law-abiding citizen I'm just getting
warmed up
it's Von Klaus with total
I'm gonna pull the whole thing down
diseased corrupt Temple down on your
head
It's gotta be biblical
in Law Abiding Citizen Butler plays
Clyde Shelton an honorable family man
whose life takes a tragic turn when his
wife and daughter are murdered during a
home invasion he hopes for justice but a
rising prosecutor named Nick rice played
by Jamie Foxx is unable to properly
convict the killer due to mishandled
evidence Ten Years Later Sheldon catches
up to the man responsible for the murder
and well tortures and dismembers him
it's actually one of the most brutal
killings in any movie ever obviously the
guy was a scumbag and deserved to be
taken down but uh Shelton might have
taken it a tad too far it was the
ceiling mirror really necessary Law
Abiding Citizen makes a statement on the
legal system which many feel is
corrupted and often fails to bring
dangerous criminals to Justice I don't
think so let's
back what did I say
that I wanted to kill Clarence Darby
yeah sure what father wouldn't
that both Darby and Ames deserve to die
I think most people would agree with
that that I planned it over and over
again in my head yeah
who wouldn't fantasize about that none
of these are an admission of guilt Nick
you might want to check the tape we know
you did it well it's not what you know
it's what you can prove in court did you
that once in the case of Butler's
character Shelton he was compelled to
take matters into his own hands making
this a thought-provoking vigilante
Thriller you'll probably find yourself
wondering who the bad guy really is by
the end of it originally Fox was cast in
the role of Shelton and Butler was
slated to play Nick rice but they ended
up switching roles funny enough Fox and
Butler would both go on to star in films
about The White House being taken over
by terrorists released in the same
calendar year the law-abiding citizen
received mixed reviews with some
criticizing it for being too graphic it
was a box office success grossing just
under
128 million dollars
Machine Gun Preacher
[Music]
once you cross your arms
and your obedience to the word of God
regarding his death burial and
Resurrection I do indeed baptize you in
the name of our Lord Jesus Christ for
the remission of your sins
next up Machine Gun Preacher directed
and produced by Mark Foster The Man
Behind the films monsters balls Stranger
Than Fiction and World War Z in his
biographical drama Butler plays Sam
Childers a former biker who decides to
go to East Africa to help repair homes
that have been destroyed by Civil War
transformed by the horrors he Witnesses
Sam ignores the warnings of more
experienced Aid workers and breaks
ground for an orphanage in the heart of
a territory controlled by a brutal
Renegade militia but he doesn't stop
there determined to save as many lives
as possible Sam leads armed missions
into enemy territory to rescue kidnap
children Butler's character is based on
the real Sam Childers who is known as
the machine gun creature in real life
screenwriter Jason Keller adapted
Childer's book another man's War about
his life as a former biker gang member
turned preach teacher and defender of
South Sudanese orphans cannot make them
work
this is the only one you have
[Music]
okay put your hand
that little Vector might still be hot
I'll be ready
what about you preacher
we're staying
[Music]
go off get out of here
inspired by Childers and his story that
he worked for a small fraction of what
his normal rate would have been for a
future and during filming he would carry
pictures of child victims whose homes
were raided in southern Sudan it's an
emotional film one made more compelling
by its truthful nature the London
evening standard praised Butler's
performance calling him evolving even
charismatic and always plausible as a
man of contained and then uncontained
violence additionally film comment
magazine wrote that even during the
biopic's most absurd moments Gerard
Butler is terrific conveying gentle and
brutal equally well
Royal anus my Noble of friends I crave
their pardons for the mutable
ranks-centered many let them regard me
as I do not flatter and therein behold
themselves I say again in soothing them
we nourish against our Senate the cockle
of rebellion insolence sedition which we
ourselves have plowed for sowed and
Scattered by mingling them with us the
honored number who lack not virtue no
nor power but that which we have given
to Beggars Corey elanus was directed by
and stars Ray fines and is an adaptation
of William Shakespeare's tragedy of the
same name finds plays Caius Martius AKA
coriolanus an arrogant and fearsome
General who has built himself a career
as the protector of Rome pushed by his
ambitious mother to seek the position of
Consul coriolanus is at odd with the
masses and unpopular with certain
colleagues when a riot results in
expulsion from Rome Corey Elena seeks
out his sworn enemy soulist of fidi is
played by Butler and together the hair
vowed to destroy the great City you
might have been thinking that the world
didn't really need another contemporary
version of a Shakespearean tell but then
again did the world really need another
Comet movie after Armageddon and deep
impact the answer is yes Greenland also
coriolanus was written like 400 years
ago so a little makeover was probably an
order no offense to Shakespeare I'll
fight with none but they
foreign
finds and Butler command your attention
especially in that one scene where they
engage in a brutal knife fight which
took two days to shoot and has made all
the more impressive by the fact that
this was Fine's debut as a director even
sir Ian McKellen who has been performing
Shakespeare on stage since he was 12
years old has listed finds betrayal of
coriolatis as one of his favorite ever
Shakespearean performances on film as if
that wasn't enough this movie was
universally praised by critics with the
Atlantic calling it genre writing that
entertains while tapping into enduring
truths and Time Magazine writing that
finds his Bleak overview should leave
receptive viewers feeling daunted and
haunted but enough about fives did you
know that Butler's first stage role and
his first real foray into acting within
a production of Corey elanus you know
what they say what Fates imposed that
men must needs abide it boots not to
resist both wind and Tide
Rock and roller
Bob
you know what's happening
there is a puff
oh come on everyone knows it's a flamer
you're the only one that doesn't no he
likes the boys
there's sausage and beans all day long
mate
did he make a part of you
it's always a problem hey it was
supposed to abuse last night you took
care of him that's what friends do for
one another well done next up is rock
and roller written and directed by
acclaimed English director Guy Ritchie
it's a story of an old school mobster
named Lenny Cole played by Tom Wilkinson
who rules London's underworld with an
Iron Fist and a score of well-greased
Palms as big time gangsters and Petty
Crooks all scrambled to get their cut of
a Russian mobster's crooked land deals
StreetWise Hustler one two Butler tries
to play both sides of the fence as the
lucrative deal falls into the lap of
Lenny's presumed dead son in addition to
Wilkinson and Butler the film also Stars
candy Wayne Newton Idris Elba and Tom
Hardy
it's just about time once
I mean we can always come back a bit
later
many saw this film as a return to form
for Richie Who Rose to prominence
following the success of his totally
similar Ensemble cash driven hit Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels but rock
and rolla is wildly entertaining in its
own way fast paced and filled with style
and swag one particularly hilarious
scene between Butler's character and his
love interest played by Newton happened
by accident because Newton refused to
kiss Butler on the day of the shoot and
she had good reason Butler had come down
with a nasty cold and according to
Newton guy was forced to improvise and
it ended up being one of the most
brilliant scenes watch the movie you'll
know what I'm talking about there Rock
and roller hit number one at the UK box
office in its first week of release and
has gained a cult following over the
years also that soundtrack is
magnificent Cop Shop hey Anthony you
know I'm not responding to that name
Anthony yeah I'm not responding to this
name Bob you heard doesn't uh Joe to
Tino and Chicago of a sixty five
thousand dollar sticker on your head
he does indeed Bob and all he's gotten
back are the headphones he sent to
collect mine
clear off my contract now Anthony or his
God is my witness I'm going to cut off
your head put it in a bag and
drive it to Chicago I shoot you not
meow lastly but certainly not least is
Cop Shop directed by Joe Carnahan and
based on a story by Kurt McLeod and Mark
Williams this one Stars Butler as Bob
vittich a professional Hitman Frank
Grillo as Teddy moretto a con artist and
Alexis louder as Valerie young a rookie
police officer set in a small town
police station these eccentric
characters intersect and young finds
herself caught in the crosshairs louder
may be the soul woman in this high
energy 70s inspired Thriller but she
shines with her deadpan humor and brings
an unrivaled pool factor to her cop
character not to mention she performs an
emergency tracheotomy and applies first
aid to her own potentially fatal wounds
ballet
what
pirate code
a temporary ceasefire and achieve a
common end
as in this end
a little lost lamb is dead just yet
I'll let you send them off
revenge for your family
here Butler plays a likable and sensible
killer someone you kind of root for and
certainly don't mind seeing flexing
their assassin skill set New York
Magazine wrote that Pop Shop inhabits an
enviable Goldilocks zone for movies
about dudes getting their heads blown
off and called it clever but not cute
Savage but not depressing and cartoonish
but not asinine and roger.com wrote that
if the idea of a cage match between
gorilla and Butler that's set in mostly
separate cages until it is in sounds
like guy movie heaven to you well Ascend
at will and there you have it our
selections for the best Gerard Butler
action movies as always we couldn't
mention every film that falls into this
category on this list but we have got
plenty of new episodes of RT Essentials
coming your way so if we missed a
selection you feel strongly about fear
not I am certain we'll get to it soon
enough thanks for tuning in I'm Perry
nemrov I'll leave you with some
inspirational words courtesy of Mr
Butler himself be the hero of your own
life story
[Applause]
[Music]